[Music]
Alex de Tocqueville so a 19th century
French thinker I mean we easily teach
Tocqueville and American political
thought courses but he's actually French
and is actually in many ways his
concerns were very French
so I mean his primary work is masterwork
as the two-volume democracy in America
which he wrote after having a kind of
extended stay and extended tour of
American so there's a lot of great stuff
in there there's a lot of great stuff
about American associational life the
way that Americans they practice a
unique form of democratic liberty in
that list there you know the organized
new small towns but the small towns
themselves are really in some sense
their communities in their active
communities so if they need a bridge
built if they need a church build
whatever it happens to be they get
together they say we're all there are
you know we we are the people that are
capable of doing this we're you know
there's no one coming to help us when I
can't apply for a blockade grant or
something like that right we want to
build the church we're going to do it
and so they build up what Robert Putnam
later called from social capital and
they live free in essence and
Tocqueville is is very enthusiastic
about this about the way that Americans
are organizing this way but for the most
part what democracy in America is is
that the kind of --all I mean what the
way I see it is it's kind of a long
meditation on what you might call the
fact of democracy so de Tocqueville
himself had a kind of aristocratic
background his concerns you might say
were aristocrats in nature he was
interested in in some sense diagnosing
and coming to understand this great new
sweep this this kind of torrent I think
in the opening he compares it to a kind
of a river that's flowing through the
West right that all these these old
aristocracies this old way of living
this is beings were washed away and in
its place is coming this new thing
democracy by which he means you know
Gullit arianism means a number of
different things and so he's just got
all these interesting chapters on the
effect of democracy on things like on
marriage on family size there's a
chapter on the the effect that democracy
and democratic norms have on the size of
headstones for you know when people die
and things like that so in other words
how should they be and I don't exactly
how big they'll be and I mean all the
things so for him in many ways it's a
kind of a sociological critique of what
democracy is going to mean for our
political institutions what's going to
mean for individual liberty what it's
going to mean for some I mean I think
really what he's worried about is some
sense of national greatness in other
words and for him the Americans did it
right and he worried very much that the
French did it incorrectly they did it
wrongly and that they're gonna pay for
it down the line yeah
do you think that if he was here today
he might think that America has actually
started to do it wrong yeah when you
talk about Liberty and things of that
nature it does seem like we might be
going more the French right answer yeah
so I mean in the second book in
particular he has a lot of talk about
what he called soft despotism and fought
despotism is something that that worried
him that he thought would be a kind of a
something that was uniquely well-suited
to a democratic country and so what's
the basic idea of soft despotism is like
listen art is a democracy going to
accept some you know a tyrant who comes
in and makes them work long hours and
develops kind of stuff no he's not
they're not going to accept that they're
not going to accept a kind of
traditional full retirement right who
just you know enriches themselves at the
public expense most kind stuff what
they're going to accept is this off is a
soft despot it that's what it comes in
and says listen you don't need to you
know to build your own bridges for
example you don't need to provide for
the poor in your own communities I'll do
all this stuff for you right I will we
can just kind of centralize this sort of
thing I'll take care of it it's much
more efficient if I do it anyway I'll
take a lot of this kind of
responsibility off your hands and for
Tocqueville this he worried that this
would have a kind of innervating effect
on people that instead of going out and
building that bridge or building that
that church or whatever it happens to be
instead of going out interacting with
each other in communities building up
trusts solving problems together in a
local way that we would instead right if
we want to build a bridge we might come
together long enough to fill out an
application of a federal greater than
send it all right so maybe we outsource
the very things that make us a community
sorted that say that that's a really
good way of putting in actually yeah so
that I think is his fear is that we've
you know abdicated basically these
powers the powers of self-government
we've said listen we don't we're tired
of governing ourselves in some sense
these are some of these decisions or
their great responsibilities some of
these decisions we don't particularly
like anyway we don't like making and so
we'll just sort of hand them over and
and live in a in a softer and more
comfortable Sorel playing yeah for the
people watching that would say we'll let
the problem with that why is that about
well I mean was it what's the problem
right I mean there's a sense it's an
active question I mean there is that is
an open question I think right so it's
no question terms so today you know we
we've got these amazing TVs and got
these amazing video games and we've got
amazing everything and there is a
certain sense in which listen if if if
what we were building in the future is
this kind of uh we in philosophy would
call a kind of a heat on machine right
so we just kind of plug ourselves into a
pleasure machine what's wrong with the
pleasure machine like what's wrong with
just being happy all the time
particularly if these more sort of
rugged individuals kind of decisions if
you know these responsibilities are in
some sense unhappy responsibilities I
don't want to have to build this bridge
if I die right you know I got other
things I want to do right I've got a job
I got kids I got video games I want to
watch the NBA whatever it is I want to
do I don't want to go out and build this
bridge so in other words what's wrong
with just being as happy as we can be
and if happiness means and it's the way
you phrase it outsourcing these
responsibilities and then what's wrong
with them well I did see wall-e the day
really be wall-e and I know if you
outsource all those things you become
just basically a fat blob I you know
drinking soda and write up did you do
research on me because you've mentioned
video games of basketball and I thought
oh you're
and over here in the dressing room there
was a there was an old-school NES
sitting on yeah how are your skills by
the way honey on the NES yeah this
pretty good actually it wasn't on the
game sports games I could be sports game
alright we got 15 minutes ago after this
maybe maybe will stream it for the
people alright we touched on this guy
already but I think this is probably the
person that I think is most confused in
modern discussion Karl Marx and when
people talk about Marxism I feel like
they have no idea what they're talking
about and especially as you've mentioned
conversation on Twitter can often be
crazy you see this old people calling
each other Marxists and Marx visit they
have no idea what they're saying so
let's go back yeah yeah so and so it's a
huge topic I mean so I mean you could
you could spit your entire academic
career you're I mean your entire life
going through going through Marxist
thought I mean itself it's contained in
these huge volumes so capital has great
work that was only Volume one of what we
came three volumes which itself was only
1/8 that's kind of broader project that
he thought is working on so you're
saying you can't get that all at one
point well there are there are days when
I wish that Marx would have just had a
better idea which is I listen I have to
I have 3,000 pages but I can break it
down into one thread on Twitter yeah and
that's just one work I mean hit the
Ealy's were unbelievably productive
remarkably productive over the course of
his life now we leave Andy about the
term Marx today in in strange way so I
mean somebody like Bernie Sanders right
people are talking my democratic
socialism we love throwing out these
polls to Millennials and saying do you
like apples and be like socialism and
when we act surprised when they say
socially well if their interaction with
socialism is something like what Bernie
Sanders is offering
there's nothing terribly socialistic or
Marxist about what what what Bernie is
is about so I mean Bernie is a fairly
old-school redistributionist does work
doesn't Bernie Sanders want to destroy
the state no
does Bernie Sanders want to destroy the
institution of private property no
Bernie Sanders just wants to in many
ways actually wants to reinforce the
state he wants to use the state to
redistribute wealth from those who have
too much to those who have less yeah I
think you can have all legit criticisms
yeah but that's not destroying this day
that's an interesting distinction it's
not destroying to say that's actually
tightening design screws is no I mean if
there's I mean any curse of the
distinction that has
we made when we when we talked about the
left and we use the capital L we tend to
conflate many many different attitudes
political attitudes economic attitudes
and so you know in terms of textbook
definitions we think of socials when we
think of public ownership of the means
of production so factory or so worker
owned factories but also just industries
being run in what we think of as the
public service or something like that or
to to public ends and then full-scale
communism is the complete abolition of
private property none of those things
are think are really on the table I mean
so I think in his younger days Sanders
talk about nationalizing banks or
something like but I mean for the most
part is pretty tame I mean you if you
look at Venezuela you look at Chavez you
look at things like that I mean that's
what socialism looks like I mean this is
this is these people are more serious
social in capitalist yeah
Bernays just I mean he's peddling a kind
of welfarism whatever you want to call
it well I always see people saying that
you can't look at Venezuela because it
doesn't give you the right example of
social yeah the socialist so we say that
it didn't work out the way they wanted
it to yeah I don't know I mean the 20th
century is a pretty long advert I'm we
think of it I mean a lot of that head
stuff has to be teased down so I mean we
have a very difficult time of separating
we make think as political or economic
philosophy from the rise of the
nation-state the development of
large-scale states and all that kind of
stuff and these processes they're
absolutely intertwined but they are
distinct so I think in Russia I mean a
lot of the way you had was going on
there was absolutely this unbelievably
pernicious application of Marxism in a
variety of ways and I think a lot of
libertarian 20 century libertarian
thought offers good arguments as to why
socialism will always look like that so
in other words this wasn't an accident
right this is how it's always going to
play out and here are reasons for that
so if you look at meetings if you look
at Hayek they make that case and those
are really good resources but at the
same time I mean the development of the
nation-state itself tends to be a fairly
bloody process particularly when we talk
about processes and modernization and
all this kind of stuff whether it be I
mean so if we think about World War two
right and on you know an unprecedented
Lee bloody conflict unprecedented a
bloody event can we pin from England
world war 2 on marks I don't think
reasonably we can what can we pin it on
I'm not really sure I think a lot of
these processes are sort of broader
mostly material world historical
processes that came to that that came to
fruition in a particularly awful way
when it comes to so many like mark I
mean I think you know there's a number
of things so there's Marx The Economist
so mark the economist drew largely from
classical economics he readily read a
lot of Smith you read a ton of David
Ricardo James mill and all this kind of
stuff and he attempted to in some sense
synthesize the great political
economists and he attempted to I mean
the way that I like to think about what
Marx was doing was he was attempting to
describe I mean he would say
dialectically I want to say that he was
attempting to describe the experience of
living in a commercial or bourgeois
society and so for me I think what's
most interest I think the kind of work
of Marx is that liberals should pay the
most attention to the classical approach
paid most amended to its his thoughts on
on what it's like to live in a
commercial society on what it's like to
work in a commercial society when he
talks about commodities for example in
the ways that we tend to organize our
live around commodities the way that we
tend to commodify many things in our
lives that maybe don't need to be maybe
that ought not to be commodified right
he in other words there's there's a kind
of a built-in to it there's a kind of
almost an existential critique of life
within a modern capitalist society that
I think there's no reason I think for
classical liberals to just say oh this
is coming but Marx Marx was the marks of
Marxism Marxism is bad for these variety
reasons therefore we'll just throw
everything out together
right I think with Marx I think we can
actually get a lot of purchase we can
begin to understand a lot of the
cultural and artistic critiques of
capitalism that we've been dealing with
in the 20th and 21st centuries hmm so
basically you don't have to buy the
economic theories to understand the
critique of just sort of the just sort
of the human philosophical tenants of it
so if so take something like we take to
run like tinder right with he wrote a
lot on tinder or something
you're the one who's it's quite Asus Y
pestis welcome right Davis why penguin
so there's a couple ways of looking at
tinder so one way of looking at you look
at Henry say oh this is awful
are you say this there's something
unnatural about this or something just
really messed up about people swiping
left to right treating potential life
partners essentially as I mean the way
you would look you know look at fresh
produce in soup is was bad this one's
good whatever I mean there's something a
little weird about that and so you're
you're put on the kind of a horns of
dilemma so you can either say listen
there's nothing weird about that isn't
it great that we can you know conduct
that we can lower the opportunity cost
of dating or something like that listen
in the fact that people are doing the
suggest that it makes them happy and who
are you to say they shouldn't be happy
I'm like I think they're often kind of
thrown onto that side of it yeah just
this kind of whatever kind of commercial
behavior people adopt is good just by
virtue of them adopting yeah that's that
pleasure machine you know that's right
and we in other words we don't have a
police traun footing to critique this
kind of havior I mean we we don't want
any anytime people critique other
people's behaviors and practices any
time in other people's begin to rank
different ways of life we begin to think
things get a little thorny and we want
to try away with them so I away from
that on the other side is one was saying
oh there's something wrong about it
objectifies it objectifies number the
opposite sex or i mean depending on up
here whatever it is you're shopping for
right it objectifies them it does you
know it trivializes these meaningful
relationships it does this that all the
kind of stuff and all that stuff I think
is really powerful people people get
that I mean when people hear that it
moves them in some sense and I think we
we cut ourselves off to all of these
methods of thinking about the way that
we live now because we're so intent on
keeping the economic side of things but
so works because we're so intent
essentially on on denying that there's
anything wrong at all with any of the
behaviors in any of the practices and
we've adopted in in in commercial
society so we're basically afraid to
judge because that would be against
right our sort of liberal position right
I mean so what it then puts us on a
slippery slope I mean it's it and this
is a very oldest be within liberal spot
right so this actually goes back to the
question of toleration
so I mean conservatives have
have criticized levels for very long
time and precisely because they treat
apathy as toleration because they
mistake indifference for toleration
right you're not actually tolerant of
different way of life because you're
completely and utterly unable or
unwilling to judge different ways of
life whereas I don't think liberals are
really committed to that I mean using
the course of force of the state to
enforce certain ways of life I mean
that's one thing right right but being
able to have a conversation about what
sort of practices you want to adopt what
sort of practices you think your
children ought to adopt these sorts of
conversations in other words I mean we
kind of we kind of we set ourselves off
from the kind of conversations about the
nature of the good life that communities
used to have I mean that people used to
the people used to say you know look I
think this way of life is better I think
this way of life is more meaningful I
think what you're doing here in this
particular case is is wrong I think it
you know has these effects and all this
kind of stuff I mean we really try to
shy away from that as much as we can and
I'm not sure that we're always better
off for it
[Music]
you